Donald Trump had a rally on Saturday in
Nevada and at this rally his brain
genuinely appeared to malfunction and
break he talked about a Chinese
restaurant bowling alley at which
documents were reportedly stored as if
it somehow means that what he did with
his documents at Mar-A-Lago is okay
listen to this story that Trump told
George H.W bush took millions of
documents to a former bowling alley and
a former Chinese restaurant where they
combined them so they're in a bowling
alley slash Chinese restaurant
hahaha
now what's the truth of the story the
truth is that uh when the National
Archives
um is participating in the process of
the creation of a Presidential Library
they will often
um rent or lease some space wherever uh
the library is being built or close to
where they are working and it is true
that the National Archives Nara they
leased uh what was essentially a
warehouse to temporarily store documents
for George H.W bush in College Station
Texas it was a building that at one
point was a bowling alley and part of
the building was a Chinese restaurant
Trump wants to frame it as George H.W
bush took a whole bunch of documents
just like Trump did and put him at what
was at the time a functioning bowling
alley or Chinese restaurant that's not
what happened Nara properly in control
of documents lease the space that used
to be that it has no connection
whatsoever to what Donald Trump did and
every one of these stories has like a
kernel of Truth
wrapped in 99 lies Trump going on during
this speech about when are they going to
prosecute Bill Clinton and Hillary
Clinton and all of them
I believe that what do you think yes yes
Mike
when will they investigate and prosecute
Bill Clinton Hillary Clinton George Bush
and look into what took place with
George Bush's father a very nice man and
the warehouse of documents and what
about Barack Hussein Obama Obama
potential prosecution I don't think so I
don't think they are
a Chinese restaurant at a bowling app
yeah so Trump just focusing on they
should all be prosecuted of course they
didn't do any of the things that Donald
Trump did Trump also fixating on Bill
Clinton and a sock drawer but he
pronounces it a socked bra it's a it's
it's very interesting
they're still looking for those pages
Bill Clinton took millions of documents
from the White House to a former car
dealership in Arkansas
we love Arkansas I can tell you we won
Arkansas both times also and kept
classified recordings in his sock draw
sock draw in fact he supposedly put the
information from the White House into
his socks and left them
these rallies are so insane at another
Point Trump very dangerously bragged
about how big the crowd was on January 6
2021 as if that's something to cheer
about given the hell and destruction
that that crowd Unleashed but the crowd
in Nevada seems to like it and these
corrupt people will never take a camera
and turn it around and show them how
many people are here they never do it
they're corrupt
they never do it you know I never knew
the cameras because this took place
right from they never want to show how
massive our crowd was you know the
biggest crowd I've ever seen
January
six
[Applause]
and the crowd loves it by the way the at
these rallies the crowd constantly is
booing and and sort of jeering the media
at the back of the rally the only media
at the back of these rallies are
right-wing outlets right side
broadcasting and Newsmax and Newsmax
didn't even cover Trump's Arizona rally
so I don't know what they're complaining
about uh then Trump does the Q Anon
music and during the Q Anon music he
complains about commercial airports
which by the way Trump doesn't ever go
to because he flies private and it's
weird but it's also kind of funny in a
way check this out a nation was once
revered airports are dirty and a crowded
mess you sit and wait for hours and then
are notified that the plane won't leave
and they have no idea when they will
where ticket prices have tripled they
don't have the pilots to fly the planes
and they don't seek qualified air
traffic controllers anymore yeah Trump
really very much affected by just what
goes on at airports that's absolutely
something that is an issue for him uh
last one and uh then we'll move on very
briefly to a bonus clip Trump is still
talking about Hillary's emails in 2022.
but almost as bad crooked Hillary
deleted 33 000 emails under
Congressional subpoena zavina
them although I do believe they're in
the state department
because it's very hard to get rid of
them but they acid wash very expensive I
believe they're in the state department
Trump talks about emails as if they are
physical things it's very interesting
the process that's why Nobody Does it
she had four ideas in a box and then
pounded her phones with hammers making
them totally
unrecognizable to the naked eye so she
took those phones and she pounded the
hell out of them yeah so there's the
Hillary story and then here's just a
bonus check this out here is a woman a
Fiore I forget This Woman's first name
she just makes up unemployment numbers
that are completely untrue but the crowd
doesn't know any better
under President Trump we had a little
over three percent unemployment oh okay
do you know last time that happened was
1969
under Biden and Obama were at 10 percent
right and even more now that's
completely untrue we are at 3.5 percent
unemployment right now she says we are
at over 10 percent unemployment the
crowd doesn't seem to think much of it
these are just obvious lies but that
crowd welcomes all of it these rallies
continue to demonstrate the level of
delusion
and disconnection from reality that
these folks have and when we talk about
well how do we get them back how do we
get them back to sense it to to Common
Sense and normality
I don't know the answer because they
will accept whatever they are told later
in the show we'll see some interviews
with the rally goers all of these clips
if you're listening today you want to
see them in their full Glory destructive
Glory uh we'll have them on our
Instagram which you can find at
davidpackman show very quick break and
right back right now many of us are
asking ourselves what's the best way to
help the people affected by the recent
hurricanes and the truth is giving them
cash is one of the best things you can
do because cash is so cost effective
when you give families cash you're also
empowering them to choose for themselves
how to best improve their situation and
I've talked before about our sponsor
give directly give directly is a
non-profit that just lets donors like
you send cash directly to families who
need it the most give directly is a
great organization I've been following
for years a lot of their focus is on
impoverished families in Africa but
right now give directly as also so
allowing you to send cash directly to
families impacted by hurricanes Ian and
Fiona during Hurricane Ian more than two
and a half million people were ordered
to leave their homes expenses are rising
they need food shelter Transportation
hurricane Fiona hit Puerto Rico on
September 18th more than 12 000 people
displaced the island is still in a state
of emergency and people need help visit
give directly.org Pacman to learn more
and send money directly to someone who
needs it the link is down below